BIDEN SITTING DOWN.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> MY FELLOW AMERICANS, PLEASE,
IF YOU HAVE A SEAT, TAKE IT.
I SPEAK TO YOU TONIGHT FROM
SACRED GROUND IN AMERICA.
INDEPENDENCE HALL IN
PHILADELPHIA, PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS IS WHERE AMERICA MADE ITS
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE TO
THE WORLD MORE THAN TWO
CENTURIES AGO WITH AN IDEA
UNIQUE AMONG NATIONS THAT IN
AMERICA, WE ARE ALL CREATED
EQUAL.
THIS IS WHERE THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION WAS WRITTEN AND
DEBATED.
THIS IS WHERE WE SET IN MOTION
THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY
EXPERIMENT OF SELF-GOVERNMENT
THE WORLD HAS EVER KNOWN.
WITH THREE SIMPLE WORDS, "WE THE
PEOPLE."
WE THE PEOPLE.
THESE TWO DOCUMENTS AND THE
IDEAS THEY EMBODY OF QUALITY AND
DEMOCRACY ARE THE ROCK UPON
WHICH THIS NATION IS BUILT.
THEY ARE HOW WE BECAME THE
GREATEST NATION ON EARTH.
THEY ARE WHY FOR MORE THAN TWO
CENTURIES AMERICA HAS BEEN A
BEACON TO THE WORLD.
BUT AS I STAND HERE TONIGHT,
EQUALITY AND DEMOCRACY ARE UNDER
ASSAULT.
WE DO OURSELVES NO FAVOR TO
PRETEND OTHERWISE, SO TONIGHT
I'VE COME TO THIS PLACE WHERE IT
ALL BEGAN TO SPEAK AS PLAINLY AS
I CAN TO THE NATION.
ABOUT THE THREATS WE FACE, ABOUT
THE POWER WE HAVE IN OUR OWN
HANDS TO MEET THESE THREATS, AND
ABOUT THE INCREDIBLE FUTURE THAT
LIES IN FRONT OF US IF ONLY WE
CHOOSE IT.
WE MUST NEVER FORGET, WE THE
PEOPLE, ARE THE TRUE HEIRS OF
THE AMERICAN EXPERIMENT THAT
BEGAN MORE THAN TWO CENTURIES
AGO.
WE THE PEOPLE, HAVE BURNING
INSIDE EACH OF US, THE FLAME OF
LIBERTY THAT WAS LIT HERE AT
INDEPENDENCE HALL.
A FLAME THAT LIT OUR WAY THROUGH
ABOLITION, THE CIVIL WAR,
SUFFRAGE, THE GREAT DEPRESSION,
WORLD WARS, CIVIL RIGHTS.
THAT SACRED FLAME STILL BURNS.
NOW ON OUR TIME, AS WE BUILD AN
AMERICA THAT IS MORE PROSPEROUS,
FREE AND JUST.
THAT IS THE WORK OF MY
PRESIDENCY, A MISSION I BELIEVE
IN WITH MY WHOLE SOUL.
BUT FIRST, WE MUST BE HONEST
WITH EACH OTHER AND WITH
OURSELVES.
TOO MUCH OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
OUR COUNTRY TODAY IS NOT NORMAL.
DONALD TRUMP AND THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS REPRESENT AN
EXTREMISM THAT THREATENS THE
VERY FOUNDATIONS OF OUR
REPUBLIC.
NOW, I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR,
VERY CLEAR UP FRONT.
NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN, NOT EVEN
THE MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS ARE
MAGA REPUBLICANS.
NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN EMBRACES
THEIR EXTREME IDEOLOGY.
I KNOW BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK WITH THESE MAINSTREAM
REPUBLICANS.
BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TODAY IS
DOMINATED, DRIVEN AND
INTIMIDATED BY DONALD TRUMP AND
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS.
AND THAT IS A THREAT TO THIS
COUNTRY.
THESE ARE HARD THINGS, BUT I'M
AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT, NOT A
PRESIDENT OF RED AMERICA OR BLUE
AMERICA, BUT OF ALL AMERICA.
AND I BELIEVE IT'S MY DUTY, MY
DUTY TO LEVEL WITH YOU TO TELL
THE TRUTH, NO MATTER HOW
DIFFICULT, NO MATTER HOW
PAINFUL.
AND HERE IN MY VIEW IS WHAT IS
TRUE.
MAGA REPUBLICANS DO NOT RESPECT
THE CONSTITUTION.
THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW.
THEY DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE.
THEY REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF A FREE ELECTION.
AND THEY'RE WORKING RIGHT NOW AS
I SPEAK IN STATE AFTER STATE TO
GIVE POWER TO DECIDE ELECTIONS
IN AMERICA TO PARTISANS AND
CRONIES, EMPOWERING ELECTION
DENIERS TO UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY
ITSELF.
MAGA FORCES ARE DETERMINED TO
TAKE THIS COUNTRY BACKWARDS.
BACKWARDS TO AN AMERICA WHERE
THERE IS NO RIGHT TO CHOOSE, NO
RIGHT TO PRIVACY, NO RIGHT TO
CONTRACEPTION, NO RIGHT TO MARRY
WHO YOU LOVE.
THEY PROMOTE AUTHORITARIAN
LEADERS AND THEY FAN THE FLAMES
OF POLITICAL VIOLENCE THAT ARE A
THREAT TO OUR PERSONAL RIGHTS,
TO THE PURSUIT OF JUSTICE, TO
THE RULE OF LAW, TO THE VERY
SOUL OF THIS COUNTRY.
THEY LOOK AT THE MOB THAT
STORMED THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th, BRUTALLY
ATTACKING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NOT AS INSURRECTIONISTS, WHO
PLACED A DAGGER AT THE THROAT OF
OUR DEMOCRACY, BUT THEY LOOK AT
THEM AT PATRIOTS AND THEY SEE
THEIR MAGA FAILURE TO STOP A
PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF POWER AFTER
THE 2020 ELECTION AS PREPARATION
FOR THE 2022 AND 2024 ELECTIONS.
THEY TRIED EVERYTHING LAST TIME
TO NULLIFY THE VOTES OF 81
MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS TIME, THEY'RE DETERMINED TO
SUCCEED IN THWARTING THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY RESPECTED
CONSERVATIVES LIKE FEDERAL
CIRCUIT COURT JUDGE MICHAEL
LUDIG HAS CALLED TRUMP AND
EXTREME MAGA REPUBLICANS, QUOTE,
A CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER TO
OUR DEMOCRACY.
WHILE THE THREAT TO AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY IS REAL, I WANT TO SAY
AS CLEARLY AS WE CAN WE ARE NOT
POWERLESS IN THE FACE OF THESE
THREATS.
WE ARE NOT BYSTANDERS IN THIS
ONGOING ATTACK ON DEMOCRACY.
THERE ARE FAR MORE AMERICANS,
FAR MORE AMERICANS FROM EVERY
BACKGROUND AND BELIEF WHO REJECT
THE EXTREME MAGA IDEOLOGY THAN
THOSE THAT ACCEPT IT.
AND FOLKS, IT'S WITHIN OUR
POWER, IT'S IN OUR HANDS, YOURS
AND MINE, TO STOP THE ASSAULT ON
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
I BELIEVE AMERICA IS AT AN
INFLECTION POINT.
ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS THAT
DETERMINE THE SHAPE OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S TO COME AFTER.
AND NOW AMERICA MUST CHOOSE TO
MOVE FORWARD OR TO MOVE
BACKWARDS.
TO BUILD A FUTURE OR OBSESS
ABOUT THE PAST.
TO BE A NATION OF HOPE AND UNITY
AND OPTIMISM, OR A NATION OF
FEAR, DIVISION AND OF DARKNESS.
MAGA REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE THEIR
CHOICE.
THEY EMBRACE ANGER.
THEY THRIVE ON CHAOS.
THEY LIVE NOT IN THE LIGHT OF
TRUTH BUT IN THE SHADOW OF LIES.
BUT TOGETHER, TOGETHER WE CAN
CHOOSE A DIFFERENT PATH.
WE CAN CHOOSE A BETTER PATH.
FORWARD TO THE FUTURE.
A FUTURE OF POSSIBILITY, A
FUTURE TO BUILD AND DREAM AND
HOPE.
AND WE'RE ON THAT PATH MOVING
AHEAD.
I KNOW THIS NATION.
I KNOW YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I KNOW YOUR COURAGE.
I KNOW YOUR HEARTS.
AND I KNOW OUR HISTORY.
THIS IS A NATION THAT HONORS OUR
CONSTITUTION.
WE DO NOT REJECT IT.
THIS IS A NATION THAT BELIEVES
IN THE RULE OF LAW.
WE DO NOT REPUDIATE IT.
THIS IS A NATION THAT RESPECTS
FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS.
WE HONOR THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
WE DO NOT DENY IT.
AND THIS IS A NATION THAT
REJECTS VIOLENCE AS A POLITICAL
TOOL.
WE DO NOT ENCOURAGE VIOLENCE.
WE ARE STILL AN AMERICA THAT
BELIEVES IN HONESTY AND DECENCY
AND RESPECT FOR OTHERS.
PATRIOTISM, LIBERTY, JUSTICE FOR
ALL, HOPE, POSSIBILITIES.
WE ARE STILL AT OUR CORE A
DEMOCRACY.
AND YET, HISTORY TELLS US THE
BLIND LOYALTY TO A SINGLE LEADER
AND A WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN
POLITICAL VIOLENCE IS FATAL TO
DEMOCRACY.
FOR A LONG TIME WE TOLD
OURSELVES THAT AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY IS GUARANTEED.
BUT IT'S NOT.
WE HAVE TO DEFEND IT, PROTECT
IT, STAND UP FOR IT, EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US.
THAT'S WHY TONIGHT I'M ASKING
OUR NATION TO COME TOGETHER,
UNITE BEHIND THE SINGLE PURPOSE
OF DEFENDING OUR DEMOCRACY
REGARDLESS OF YOUR IDEOLOGY.
WE'RE ALL CALLED BY DUTY AND
CONSCIENCE TO CONFRONT
EXTREMISTS WHO PUT THEIR OWN
PURSUIT OF POWER ABOVE ALL ELSE.
DEMOCRATS, INDEPENDENTS,
MAINSTREAM REPUBLICANS, WE MUST
BE STRONGER, MORE DETERMINED AND
MORE COMMITTED TO SAVING
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY THAN MAGA
REPUBLICANS ARE TO DESTROYING
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
WE THE PEOPLE WILL NOT LET
ANYONE OR ANYTHING TEAR US
APART.
TODAY THERE ARE DANGERS AROUND
US.
WE CANNOT ALLOW TO PREVAIL.
YOU'VE HEARD IT.
MORE AND MORE TALK ABOUT
VIOLENCE AS AN ACCEPTABLE
POLITICAL TOOL IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT.
IT CAN NEVER BE AN ACCEPTABLE
TOOL.
SO I WANT TO SAY THIS PLAIN AND
SIMPLE.
THERE IS NO PLACE FOR POLITICAL
VIOLENCE IN AMERICA, PERIOD,
NONE, EVER.
YOU SAW LAW ENFORCEMENT BRUTALLY
ATTACKED ON JANUARY THE 6th.
WE'VE SEEN ELECTION OFFICIALS,
POLL WORKERS, MANY OF THEM
VOLUNTEERS OF BOTH PARTIES
SUBJECT TO INTIMIDATION AND
DEATH THREATS.
AND CAN YOU BELIEVE IT, FBI
AGENTS JUST DOING THEIR JOB AS
DIRECTED FACING THREATS TO THEIR
OWN LIVES FROM THEIR OWN FELLOW
CITIZENS.
ON TOP OF THAT, THERE ARE PUBLIC
FIGURES TODAY, YESTERDAY AND THE
DAY BEFORE PREDICTING AND ALL
BUT CALLING FOR MASS VIOLENCE
AND RIOTING IN THE STREETS.
THIS IS INFLAMMATORY.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
IT'S AGAINST THE RULE OF LAW.
AND WE THE PEOPLE MUST SAY THIS
IS NOT WHO WE ARE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE CAN'T
BE PRO INSURRECTIONIST AND PRO
AMERICAN.
THEY'RE INCOMPATIBLE.
WE CAN'T ALLOW VIOLENCE TO BE
NORMALIZED IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S WRONG.
WE EACH HAVE TO REJECT POLITICAL
VIOLENCE WITH ALL THE MORAL
CLARITY AND CONVICTION THIS
NATION CAN MUSTER NOW.
WE CAN'T LET THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR ELECTIONS BE UNDERMINED, FOR
THAT IS A PATH TO CHAOS.
LOOK, I KNOW POLITICS CAN BE
FIERCE AND MEAN AND NASTY IN
AMERICA.
I GET IT.
I BELIEVE IN THE GIVE AND TAKE
OF POLITICS, IN DISAGREEMENT AND
DEBATE AND DISSENT.
WE'RE A BIG, COMPLICATED
COUNTRY.
BUT DEMOCRACY ENDURES ONLY IF WE
THE PEOPLE RESPECT THE
GUARDRAILS OF THE REPUBLIC.
ONLY IF WE THE PEOPLE ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS.
ONLY IF WE THE PEOPLE SEE
POLITICS NOT AS TOTAL WAR, BUT
MEDIATION OF OUR DIFFERENCES.
DEMOCRACY CANNOT SURVIVE WHEN
ONE SIDE BELIEVES THERE ARE ONLY
TWO OUTCOMES TO AN ELECTION,
EITHER THEY WIN OR THEY WERE
CHEATED.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS ARE TODAY.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT EVERY
PATRIOTIC AMERICAN KNOWS.
YOU CAN'T LOVE YOUR COUNTRY ONLY
WHEN YOU WIN.
IT'S FUNDAMENTAL.
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY ONLY WORKS
ONLY IF WE CHOOSE TO RESPECT THE
RULE OF LAW AND THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT WERE SET UP IN THIS CHAMBER
BEHIND ME.
ONLY IF WE RESPECT OUR
LEGITIMATE POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES.
I WILL NOT STAND BY AND WATCH.
I WILL NOT LET THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BE OVERTURNED BY
WILD CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
BASELESS EVIDENCE OF CLAIMS OF
FRAUD.
I WILL NOT STAND BY AND WATCH
ELECTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY STOLEN
BY PEOPLE WHO SIMPLY REFUSE TO
ACCEPT THAT THEY LOST.
I WILL NOT STAND BY AND WATCH
THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOM IN
THIS COUNTRY, THE FREEDOM TO
VOTE AND HAVE YOUR VOTE COUNTED
AND BE TAKEN FROM YOU AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
LOOK, AS YOUR PRESIDENT, I WILL
DEFEND OUR DEMOCRACY WITH EVERY
FIBER IN MY BEING.
AND I'M ASKING EVERY AMERICAN TO
JOIN ME.
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY, AMERICA
HAS OFTEN MADE THE GREATEST
PROGRESS COMING OUT OF SOME OF
OUR DARKEST MOMENTS LIKE YOU'RE
HEARING THAT BULL HORN.
I BELIEVE WE CAN AND MUST DO
THAT AGAIN AND WE ARE.
MAGA REPUBLICANS LOOK AT AMERICA
AND SEE CARNAGE AND DARKNESS AND
DESPAIR.
THEY SPREAD FEAR AND LIES.
LIES TOLD FOR PROFIT AND POWER.
BUT I SEE A DIFFERENT AMERICA,
AN AMERICA WITH AN UNLIMITED
FUTURE, AN AMERICA THAT'S ABOUT
TO TAKE OFF.
I HOPE YOU SEE IT AS WELL.
JUST LOOK AROUND.
I BELIEVE WE COULD LIFT AMERICA
FROM THE DEPTHS OF COVID SO WE
PASSED THE LARGEST ECONOMIC
PACKAGE SINCE FRANKLIN DELANO
ROOSEVELT AND TODAY AMERICA'S
ECONOMY IS FASTER, STRONGER THAN
ANY OTHER ADVANCED NATION IN THE
WORLD.
WE HAVE MORE TO GO.
I BELIEVE WE CAN BUILD A BETTER
AMERICA SO WE PASSED THE BIGGEST
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT SINCE
PRESIDENT DWIGHT D. EISENHOWER
AND WE'VE EMBARKED ON REBUILDING
THE NATION'S ROADS, BRIDGES,
HIGHWAYS, PORTS, HIGH-SPEED
INTERNET, RAILROADS.
I BELIEVE WE CAN MAKE AMERICA
SAFER, SO WE PASSED THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT GUN SAFETY LAW SINCE
PRESIDENT CLINTON.
I BELIEVE WE COULD GO FROM BEING
THE HIGHEST COST OF
PRESCRIPTIONS TO THE WORLD TO
MAKING PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND
HEALTH CARE MORE AFFORDABLE, SO
WE PASSED THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH CARE REFORM SINCE
PRESIDENT OBAMA SIGNED THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
AND I BELIEVED WE COULD CREATE A
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE AND SAVE THE
PLANET, SO WE PASSED THE MOST
IMPORTANT CLIMATE INITIATIVE
EVER, EVER, EVER.
THE CYNICS AND THE CRITICS TELL
US NOTHING CAN GET DONE, BUT
THEY'RE WRONG.
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE THING
AMERICA CANNOT DO, NOT A SINGLE
THING BEYOND OUR CAPACITY IF WE
DO IT TOGETHER.
IT'S NEVER EASY.
BUT WE'RE PROVING THAT AMERICA,
NO MATTER HOW LONG THE ROAD,
PROGRESS DOES COME.
LOOK, I KNOW THE LAST YEAR, FEW
YEARS HAVE BEEN TOUGH, BUT TODAY
COVID NO LONGER CONTROLS OUR
LIVES.
MORE AMERICANS ARE WORKING THAN
EVER.
BUSINESSES ARE GROWING, OUR
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN, MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN LIFTED OUT
OF POVERTY.
MILLIONS OF VETERANS ONCE
EXPOSED TO TOXIC BURN PITS WILL
NOW GET WHAT THEY DESERVE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES IN COMPENSATION.
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING HAS COME
ALIVE ACROSS THE HEARTLAND AND
THE FUTURE WILL BE MADE IN
AMERICA.
NO WHAT ARE THE WHAT THE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS AND THE EXTREMISTS
SAY.
I MADE A BET ON YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND THAT BET IS
PAYING OFF, PROVING THAT FROM
DARKNESS, THE DARKNESS OF
CHARLOTTESVILLE, OF COVID, OF
GUN VIOLENCE, OF INSURRECTION,
WE CAN SEE THE LIGHT.
LIGHT IS NOW VISIBLE.
LIGHT THAT WILL GUIDE US
FORWARD.
NOT ONLY IN WORDS BUT IN
ACTIONS.
ACTIONS FOR YOU, FOR YOUR
CHILDREN, FOR YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN, FOR AMERICA.
EVEN IN THIS MOMENT WITH ALL THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE, I GIVE YOU
MY WORD AS A BIDEN, I'VE NEVER
BEEN MORE OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
AMERICA'S FUTURE.
NOT BECAUSE OF ME, BUT BECAUSE
OF WHO YOU ARE.
WE'RE GOING TO END CANCER AS WE
KNOW IT, MARK MY WORDS.
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE MILLIONS
OF NEW JOBS AND A CLEAN ENERGY
ECONOMY.
WE'RE GOING TO THINK BIG.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THE 21st
CENTURY ANOTHER AMERICAN
CENTURY, BECAUSE THE WORLD NEEDS
US TO.
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO FOCUS
OUR ENERGY.
NOT IN THE PAST, NOT ON DIVISIVE
CULTURE WARS, NOT ON THE
POLITICS OF GRIEVANCE, BUT ON A
FUTURE WE CAN BUILD TOGETHER.
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS BELIEVE
THAT FOR THEM TO SUCCEED,
EVERYONE ELSE HAS TO FAIL.
THEY BELIEVE AMERICA NOT WHAT I
BELIEVE ABOUT AMERICA.
I BELIEVE AMERICA IS BIG ENOUGH
FOR ALL OF US TO SUCCEED, AND
THAT IS THE NATION WE'RE
BUILDING, A NATION WHERE NO ONE
IS LEFT BEHIND.
I RAN FOR PRESIDENT BECAUSE I
BELIEVED WE WERE IN A BATTLE OF
THE SOUL OF THIS NATION.
I STILL BELIEVE THAT TO BE TRUE.
I BELIEVE THE SOUL IS THE
BREADTH, THE LIFE AND THE
ESSENCE OF WHO WE ARE.
THE SOUL IS WHAT MAKES US, US.
THE SOUL OF AMERICA IS DEFINED
BY THE SACRED PROPOSITION THAT
ALL ARE CREATED EQUAL IN THE
IMAGE OF GOD, THAT ALL ARE
ENTITLED TO BE TREATED WITH
DECENCY, DIGNITY AND RESPECT,
THAT ALL DESERVE JUSTICE AND A
SHOT AT LIVES OF PROSPERITY AND
CONSEQUENCE, AND THAT DEMOCRACY,
DEMOCRACY MUST BE DEFENDED, FOR
DEMOCRACY MAKES ALL THESE THINGS
POSSIBLE.
FOLKS, AND IT'S UP TO US.
DEMOCRACY BEGINS AND WILL BE
PRESERVED AND WE THE PEOPLE'S
HABITS OF THE HEART, IN OUR
CHARACTER, OPTIMISM THAT IS
TESTED, YET ENDURES, COURAGE
THAT DIGS DEEP WHEN WE NEED IT.
EMPATHY THAT FUELS DEMOCRACY.
THE WILLINGNESS TO SEE EACH
OTHER NOT AS ENEMIES BUT AS
FELLOW AMERICANS.
LOOK, OUR DEMOCRACY ISN'T
PERFECT.
IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
NOTWITHSTANDING THOSE FOLKS YOU
HEAR ON THE OTHER SIDE THERE,
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO BE
OUTRAGEOUS.
THIS IS A DEMOCRACY.
BUT HISTORY AND COMMON SENSE --
[ APPLAUSE ]
GOOD MANNERS IS NOTHING THEY
HAVE EVER SUFFERED FROM.
BUT HISTORY AND COMMON SENSE
TELL US THAT OPPORTUNITY,
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL ARE
MOST LIKELY TO COME TO PASS IN A
DEMOCRACY.
WE HAVE NEVER FULLY REALIZED THE
ASPIRATIONS OF OUR FOUNDING, BUT
EVERY GENERATION HAS OPENED
THOSE DOORS A LITTLE BIT WIDER
TO INCLUDE MORE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED BEFORE.
MY FELLOW AMERICANS, AMERICA IS
AN IDEA, THE MOST POWERFUL IDEA
IN THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD AND
IT BEATS IN THE HEARTS OF THE
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
IT BEATS IN ALL OUR HEARTS.
IT UNITES AMERICA.
IT IS THE AMERICAN CREED.
THE IDEA THAT AMERICA GUARANTEES
THAT EVERYONE BE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY.
IT GIVES HATE NO SAFE HARBOR.
IT INSTALLS IN EVERYONE THE
BELIEF THAT NO MATTER WHERE YOU
START IN LIFE, THERE'S NOTHING
YOU CAN'T ACHIEVE.
THAT'S WHO WE ARE.
THAT'S WHAT WE STAND FOR.
THAT'S WHAT WE BELIEVE.
AND THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT WE'RE
DOING, OPENING DOORS, CREATING
POSSIBILITIES, FOCUSING ON THE
FUTURE, AND WE'RE ONLY JUST
BEGINNING.
OUR TASK IS TO MAKE OUR NATION
FREE AND FAIR, JUST AND STRONG,
NOBLE AND WHOLE, AND THIS WORK
IS THE WORK OF DEMOCRACY, THE
WORK OF THIS GENERATION.
IT IS THE WORK OF OUR TIME FOR
ALL TIME.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LEAVE ANYONE
ON THE SIDELINES.
WE NEED EVERYONE TO DO THEIR
PART, SO SPEAK UP, SPEAK OUT,
GET ENGAGED, VOTE, VOTE, VOTE!
AND IF WE DO OUR DUTY, IF WE DO
OUR DUTY, IN 2022 AND BEYOND,
THEN AGES STILL TO COME WILL SAY
WE, ALL OF US HERE, WE KEPT THE
FAITH.
WE PRESERVED DEMOCRACY.
WE HEEDED OUR WORDS.
WE HEEDED NOT OUR WORST
INSTINCTS BUT OUR BETTER ANGELS.
WE PROVED THAT FOR ALL ITS
IMPERFECTIONS, AMERICA IS STILL
THE BEACON TO THE WORLD, AN
IDEAL TO BE REALIZED, A PROMISE
TO BE KEPT.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT.
NOTHING MORE SACRED.
NOTHING MORE AMERICAN.
THAT'S OUR SOUL.
THAT'S WHO WE TRULY ARE.
AND THAT'S WHO WE MUST ALWAYS
BE.
I HAVE NO DOUBT, NONE, THAT THIS
IS WHO WE WILL BE AND THAT WE'LL
COME TOGETHER AS A NATION THAT
WILL SECURE OUR DEMOCRACY, THAT
FOR THE NEXT 200 YEARS WE'LL
HAVE WHAT WE HAD THE PAST 200
YEARS, THE GREATEST NATION ON
THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
WE JUST NEED TO REMEMBER WHO WE
ARE.
WE ARE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
AND MAY GOD PROTECT OUR NATION
AND MAY GOD PROTECT ALL THOSE